let's say that you have a cholesterol
test and you know you somehow magically
know that the probability that it is
accurate that it gives the correct
results
is 99.99
you have a 99 out of 100 chance that any
time you apply this test that it is
going to be accurate
now let's say that you and you just
magically know that we're just assuming
that now let's just say that you get 100
folks into this room and you apply this
test to all 100 of them so apply
apply test
100
times
so what are some of the possible
outcomes here
is it for sure that 99 exactly 99 out of
the 100 are going to be accurate and
that 1 out of 100 is going to be
inaccurate well that's definitely a
likely possibility but it's also
possible you get a little lucky and all
hundred are accurate or you're a little
unlucky and that 98 are accurate and
that two are inaccurate and actually i
calculated the probabilities ahead of
time and the goal of this video isn't to
go into the probability and
combinatorics of it but if you're
curious about it there's a lot of good
videos on probability and combinatorics
on khan academy but i calculated ahead
of time and the probability if you have
if you have something that has a 99
chance of being accurate and you apply
it 100 times the probability that is
accurate
that it is accurate 100 out of the 100
times
is approximately equal to
approximately equal to 36.6
i rounded to the nearest tenth of a
percent so it's a little better than a
third chance that you'll actually get
all of all of the people are going to
get an accurate result even though for
any one of them there's a 99 chance that
it's accurate and we could keep going
the probability that it is accurate i'm
just going to put these quotes here so i
don't have to rewrite accurate over and
over again the probability that it is
accurate 99
out of 100 times i calculated it ahead
of time it is approximately 37.0
so this is what you would expect
getting 100 out of 100 doesn't seem that
unlikely if each of the times you apply
it has a 99 chance of being accurate but
it makes sense that you that you would
expect 99 out of 100 to be even more
likely slightly more likely and we can
of course keep going the probability
that it is accurate 98
out of 100 times is approximately
18.5 percent and i'm just going to do a
few more the probability that it is
accurate
97 out of 100 times and once again i
calculated all of these ahead of time is
six percent so it's it's definitely in
the realm of possibility but it's the
probability is much lower than getting
having 99 out of 100 or 100 out of 100
being accurate and then the probability
let me put the double quotes here the
probability that it's accurate 96 out of
100 times
is approximately 1.5 percent
and then the probability and i'll just
do one more and i could keep going the
probably you know there's some
probability that even though each test
has a 99 chance you just get super
unlucky and that you know very few of
them are accurate but i'll just and you
see you see what's happening to the
probabilities as we have as as we have
fewer and fewer of them being accurate
it becomes less and less
probable so the probability that 95
out of the 100 are accurate
is
is zero approximately 0.3 percent so
this was just kind of a i guess you
could say a thought experiment if we had
a test that we know for sure that every
time you administer it the probability
that it's accurate is 99
then these are the probabilities that if
you administer it 100 times then you get
100 out of 100 accurate the probability
that you get 99 out of 100 accurate and
so on and so forth so let's just keep
that in mind and then think a little bit
about hypothesis testing and and how we
can use this framework
so let's let's put all that in the back
of our minds and let's say that you have
you have devised a new test
you have a new test
and you don't know how accurate it is
you have a new cholesterol test you
don't know how accurate it is
you know that in order for it to be
approved by whatever governing body it
has to be accurate 99 the probability of
it being accurate has to be 99
so needs
needs to
have
have probability of accurate
accurate equal to 99 you don't know if
this is true you just know that that's
what it needs to be
and so you have your test and let's say
you set up a hypothesis and your
hypothesis could be a lot of things and
once you get deeper into statistics
there's null hypothesis and alternate
hypotheses but let's just start with
just a simple hypothesis you're you're
hopeful your hypothesis
is that
your pro that the probability that your
new test
u test is accurate
is accurate is
this is your hypothesis because you you
want that to be your hypothesis because
if you if you feel good about it then
you're like okay yeah maybe i'll get
approved by the appropriate governing
body so you say hey i
my hypothesis is that my new test is
accurate 99 the probability of it being
accurate is 99
so then you go off and you apply it 100
times
so you apply
your new test you don't know the actual
probability of it being accurate you you
apply the test
you apply the test 100 times
and let's say out of those hundred times
you get that they are accurate
you get that it is accurate
and you're able to use some other test
that you you know some for sure test
some super accurate test to verify your
own test results and you see that as an
accurate 95
out of the 100 times
so the question you have is well does
the hypothesis make sense to you will
you accept this hypothesis
well what you say is well if my
hypothesis was true if my if my test
were accurate 99 if the probability of
my test being accurate is 99
what's the probability of me getting
this outcome
well we figured that out if it really
was accurate 99 of the time then the
probability of getting this outcome is
only 0.3 percent
so if you assume true
if you assume
if you assume
hypothesis
hypothesis i'll just write hype
if you assume the hypothesis is true the
probability of the outcome you got
probability of observed
observed
observed outcome
is approximately
0.3 percent
and so say look you know maybe it's
definitely possible that i just got very
very very very unlikely but based on
this
i probably should reject my hypothesis
because it the the probability of me
getting this outcome
if the hypothesis was true is very very
very very low and as we go deeper into
statistics you'll see that there are
thresholds that people often set for you
know if it's if the probability of
something happening or not happening is
above or below some threshold then we
might reject a certain hypothesis but in
in this world you could see that look if
my test really was accurate 99 of the
time for me to get when i apply it to
100 people it's only accurate 95 out of
100 if my hypothesis is true that would
have only there there's only a point
three percent chance that i would have
seen this observation so based on that
it might be completely reasonable to say
you know what
i might reject my hypothesis look for a
new test i don't feel good about this
new cholesterol test that i constructed